[Music]
there's no denying that competitive
gaming is on the rise with tournaments
for league of legends overwatch and
Street Fighter 5 entertaining millions
of viewers and rewarding millions of
dollars each year so it comes as no
surprise that breakaway Amazon's first
game from their newly established game
development studio just so happens to be
a 4v4 competitive brawler while it does
fit the profile of a typical eSports
title the game's frantic gameplay and
well-designed heroes up a refreshing if
oddly familiar experience that longs to
hang with the likes of the after
mentioned competitive gaming giants now
a MOBA this game is not but you can feel
the essence of dota or League of Legends
coursing through breakaways veins two
teams of four heroes compete to grab the
relic in the center of the arena and
deliver to the enemy base fighting off
anyone that stands in the way
breakaway offers a selection of
mythological heroes to choose from eight
in the most current alpha build each
with their own unique set of abilities
while the character design isn't the
most creative or inspired they're
recognizable enough for you to at least
understand what their strengths might be
just by looking at them big guy tank gun
guy damage lady with headdress healer
while the characters aren't exactly
memorable enough to write home about the
gameplay seems to be a strong enough
pedestal to support their shortcomings
the inclusion of buildable z' is
something that helps set Breakaway apart
from other similar games being both
offensive and defensive they cause each
team's base to assume in almost
maze-like appearance with players
capable of adding up to eight structures
each subsequent round combine this with
an upgrade system that the game
encourages you to utilize between deaths
matches can wind up being an extremely
hectic and fast-paced affair after just
a couple of rounds
and this is where the game can get a
little messy matches where players have
built up their bases can result in a
whirlwind of attacks saturating the
screen parsing through all the mayhem
can reveal a surprising inner layer of
depth and complexity but breakaway seems
to favor the chaos leading to some
exciting and seemingly unfair outcomes
holding on to the relic for longer than
a couple seconds can sometimes feel like
an impossible task every single hit that
character takes will cause a relative
change hands and by the later rounds
enemy encounters begin to feel more like
hot potato than anything else but the
strategy is still there passing the
relic to another player while you stun
an enemy heading towards you and then
dashing past them to set up an alley-oop
with a relic it's a satisfying prospect
that breakaway dangles in front of us
like a carrot on a stick
granted the game is still early in
development and players will become more
skilled as time goes on but as it stands
right now breakaway offers a very
distinct level of joy one that feels
tantamount to any other online shooter
or MOBA out there breakaway is not a
game that will blow you away with its
innovative game player groundbreaking
mechanics but it's a game that where's
its influences on sleeve it doesn't
introduce many new ideas but the ones
that retreads
helped create a solid foundation for an
exciting new take on the genre
[Music]